hey everyone so i was watching a couple
of documentaries uh on the food industry
and
it sparked us to become a little bit
healthier and eat more vegetables and
try to live a healthier lifestyle and so
i just got back from home depot bought a
whole bunch of different stuff and i'm
going to try
gardening a little bit i'm in a condo so
we don't have a ton of space but i
bought a cherry tomato plant here we've
got a green pepper plant at the back
this is uh it's an orchid right yeah
it's an orchid that nina insisted on
vine it's the most expensive thing on
the table
but we made a deal she had to keep her
area clean if she kept the orchid
and uh and two spinach plants these are
actually really cool or with the spinach
you bring this up
you can
cut the end leaves off and eat them
spinach and it continues to grow uh so
i'm excited to try that out but what
sparked this was
uh sprouts so i got this pack of sprouts
here now these are onion sprouts i don't
know what kind of the best sprouts are
to find but i was
i was inspired by a friend of mine named
phil nada from philando.com
and he grows sprouts all the time he's
done some videos on them and he just
he's popping these back as snacks and so
i thought you know what i'm going to try
it out
i didn't want to buy all the gear for it
and buy it in bulk quantities
that he usually doesn't you know try one
pack see how it goes and then
if it works keep doing more so you get
to join me on my onion sprout journey
today
so nina is going to demonstrate while i
read and narrate what's going on here so
let me load the package it says
it's as easy as soak rinse and eat eight
to fourteen days delicious and salad
sandwiches dressings and soups
okay so step number one put seed in a
wide mouth jar we're using a classico
tomato sauce jar
here's nina expertly demonstrating how
to pour seeds into a jar oh look at
those
black yeah they're black it's supposed
to have an oniony taste but we'll see
how it goes okay
cover with fine masher cheesecloth and
secure with a rubber band we don't have
a fine mesh or cheesecloth
so
a tip that i learned from phil nada is
you can use your hands
onto your hand yeah it will come up
but they'll stick to your hand
this is why you're supposed to buy the
gear oh i know what to use what
tea strainer yeah is it big enough to
cover that
oh totally big enough amazing okay there
we go
for the audience that is enraptured in
this video you know they're hanging on
every breath we gotta explain you know
here's the t-holder
okay i'd say do one more one more rinse
a bonus points for anybody watching if
you could tell me what that machine is
to nina's left
in the in behind there you can tell me
what that machine is you get you should
show the top you get serious bonus
points no no you got to be able to
recognize that i had never even heard of
this kind of machine before meeting nina
okay
all completely drained
oh okay you know what now it says soak
for four hours
so
let's fill it with some water
no i think it just has to the seeds have
to be inside
nice that's gonna be our sprouts soon
i don't know if we're supposed to cover
it i'd say leave it uncovered
okay so here are
our seeds that we're soaking for four
hours
it is 5 18 p.m so at 9 00
18 p.m we're gonna try to come back
and uh do the next step
9 23 we're a few minutes late whatever
it doesn't matter we are making some
dinner well nina's making some dinner we
got kale and cauliflower cooking up a
storm okay
our sprouts are just
sitting here in this jar let's see what
the next step is nina is very
excited okay okay ready next step
drain then rinse
at least twice a day
so do we have to rinse again now what do
you think
let's do one more rinse i'm still
curious to see if anybody guesses what
that machine is behind you
all right that's it we're going to let
it sit
booyah we'll come back tomorrow morning
and we'll see how it goes
sprouts in action
i have just finished my breakfast
checking out all my social media stuff
it's my birthday so it was a ton of
comments and everything so it's a lot of
work this morning but a lot of fun and
i'm going to check on the sprouts and
see how they're doing
so here they are
doesn't look like anything has happened
yet and uh
nina is not here so i am so low today
and i need to
rinse these
twice a day so we're gonna do a solo
rinse
i don't know if we can see it in here
some of them do have just a little bit
of a white spot coming out of them so
they are starting it's actually working
this is exciting so let's rinse it off
all right that's it
back in business
so tonight i have a birthday dinner at
my parents house and then uh some salsa
afterwards and then after that i'll come
back we'll do another rinse and see if
they keep growing
i just got back from uh salsa class it's
my birthday we had some fun
and uh
gotta come home and water the sprouts
give them another wash so i have nina
helping me again
how many rings
i think just one rinse that's all i did
this morning
oh you did way better than i did this
morning i had all the seeds in the in
the bucket took me forever to get them
out excuse skills nina's got the
the straining skills
okay
there we go that's it
this is the end of day two
mostly still just all black but a few of
them have these little white heads on
them so we'll see what they look like
tomorrow
it's wednesday and wednesday is my
filming day and so
i had my training session with jenny and
then i had susan carlucci come and teach
me about clothing work on a clothing
line and so it's almost two o'clock and
i haven't done my seats yet hopefully
that's not gonna mess us up so i gotta
watch it again
as i look into it let me bring this up
can you guys see this little the white
sprouts are starting to come up it's a
little bit bigger than it was yesterday
so this is our day three
so i'm gonna wash it again
and hopefully we'll have something to
eat pretty soon we're supposed to eat
these when they get to be an inch long
so we're still far away from that
now when i did it myself yesterday i
just poured the whole thing in here and
then had a really hard time getting them
all back so i'm going to use nina's
technique
and just try to get
all the water out without pouring it and
getting all the sprouts coming in here
ah i did it with only three
sprout seeds coming in here that's a
much better
solution
okay we'll let it sit
see what it's like later tonight
we just got back from uh from dancing i
was djing
salsa kizomba bachata night and just got
back and of course i have to work on the
sprouts
that's what's up gotta wash these
sprouts so my sink is a little bit of a
mess
we've had dinner and bunch of stuff and
i haven't cleaned it out yet but uh
that's okay
so let's check on our sprouts
see how we're doing
they are uh they are still growing
look in here you're starting to see the
white heads come out
starting to get a little bit longer
the longest one is maybe almost half a
centimeter so coming along let's rinse
them out see what happens
all right that's it for now we'll check
back in tomorrow day four
and we'll see how we're doing
so i was sitting here
thinking man this is taking a long time
you look at the sprouts so this is day
four
let me see this is the start of day four
you can kind of start to see them the
the white heads coming out a little bit
more
and i was looking at the
package and it says uh it's gonna be
ready
at the top there can you read that 8 to
14 days it takes to make this thing when
i saw the video of phil
i thought it was going to be
a couple days but 8 to 14 days is way
longer than i thought i signed up for a
big process so
let's do it again day four
that's it we'll check back in again
later today
so here's what they look like you can
see that slowly but surely they're
getting more and more white as the
sprouts are coming out
still far away from being able to eat
them but getting closer
we may try them and they and they're
terrible oh no
so you can start to see now it's not
just white to some green things coming
out of it it smells like very oniony
yeah
onion
so on the package it said it would be
ready in 8 to 14 days
and here's what it looks like so far
this is up there this is our seventh day
so you can see they're starting to come
out you're starting you're supposed to
eat them once they're about an inch long
and now they're about a centimeter so
there's still a lot of time i think
we're going to be pushing up until 14
day mark
they're getting stringy they're getting
long they're clumping together
it's supposed to be about
an inch
before we eat them but i don't think
they're that long yet there may be half
an inch so maybe it'll keep growing the
next few days if i keep watering we have
jason j rice fonsica
doing some guest sprouting with us take
off the lid all right
and then you pour some water in there
the filtered water this thing is like
adorable
for the filtered water
it's unfiltered
i usually almost fill it and then you
like
move it around
all right
spread it around so everything gets
washed if you smell it's got a serious
onion yeah it does yeah pretty strong
yeah that's pretty good that's good
shake it around
guess sprouting with jason
who would have thought jason thought
this morning i'm gonna wake up and go
wash some sprouts today keeps you on
your toes
he keeps it fresh wait are you calling
me
you're starting the trend i'm calling
you easy
okay that's it then you drain it with
the uh
the cover okay
and keep trying to keep as many sprouts
in the
jar as possible right right
and then we end up tapping it
get that water out okay
and then i usually just tap whatever's
in the
thing back in
sprouts day 11.
amazing
slowly
there you go
tonight they're gonna get eaten
very oniony
so it has been two weeks and we've been
washing day and night
our sprouts and we're finally ready to
eat them
so why don't we uh maybe give it one
last rinse
and then chow down on our sprouts
no you have to have one too it looks
nice in the water
okay
okay
no i'm gonna have one together
here
here's mine cheers
cheers that's how you're taking
yeah do you think
okay well i don't know if we did
everything right but um
that's my sprout video
i guess i have some sprouts to eat on my
own tonight
and that's it you guys like this video
thumbs up below let me know what you
think if we did something wrong
and what
have they figured out
oh yeah yeah if you know what that
machine is at the back let us know what
it is leave it in the comments thank you
guys i will see you soon we may try them
and they and they're terrible oh no